i want to talk about walking away we
have this story from ap
some democrats voting in gop primaries
to block trump picks
they going to say diane murray struggled
with her decision all the way up to the
election day but when the time came the
54 year old can we pull this up yes
sorry sir the uh 54 year old georgia
democrat cast a ballot in last week's
republican primary for secretary of
state brad raffensberger while state law
allowed her to participate in either
party's primary said it felt like a
violation of her core values to vote for
the republican but it had to be done she
decided to prevent donald trump backed
election denier from becoming the
battleground state election chief quote
i feel strongly that a democracy is at
risk and that people who are holding up
the big lie as we call it are holding on
to the former president's uh president
are dangerous to our democracy okay blah
blah blah blah
there was data that came out that showed
in georgia seven percent
of the republican primary votes were
former democrats
and the media then came out and started
saying things like this
oh this is this
this is democrats trying to sabotage
trump and i'm like that's a really bad
thing to say even if it's true that the
will of the people is being subverted by
people who are trying to
sabotage a primary but i don't believe
it's true
i don't i don't believe that seven
percent we're talking about a hundred
thousand people we're all like we're
democrats but we're gonna vote the
republican race to ruin trump's chances
is it bad that i absolutely believe it
you do believe that a hundred thousand
people who voted did it because they
hate trump i
believe it's possible i didn't say it's
not possible yeah i believe that it is
just extremely unlikely and the reality
is it's people who are like the economy
is in the gutter
the there's a food shortage of fuel
shortage and i'm paying five bucks a
gallon for gas i'm vote republican
but look i mean money talks and it
speaks much more eloquently and
effectively than any rhetoric people
have to throw what six bucks into the
pump to get a gallon of gas yeah they're
probably not going to vote for more of
the same i'll i'll to your point though
it would be foolish of any republican
conservative right wing whatever you
want to call it to ignore this story 100
because rest assured it may come
election time and you're like we got in
the bag look at the turnout from the
republican primaries record-breaking and
then all of a sudden there's a surge in
democrat votes because
they really were trying to sabotage you
uh i think it's absolutely possible that
this is an organized effort to get in
and sabotage things i do think it can
happen in the numbers that you just
described i think when you said earlier
that these people have no principles
this could absolutely be an example of
just that but wait hold my question for
you is
i understand the the state of the
country and the
the price of gas and inflation
everything pushing people over to the
right or even making the decision oh my
god i'm going to vote republican even
though i've never done that my entire
life but to switch parties and vote in
primaries i'm not so sure that's a good
point there's but i think maybe a lot of
people just don't understand what the
primaries are but but i do think it's a
good point but i will say this in 2018
about 600 000 people voted in the
republican primary
in the in the primary in 2022 it was 1.1
million
they estimated only about seven percent
were former democrats this means that
the republicans are just seeing a surge
in new voters
that says a lot
so
sorry who wants these new voters if
they're coming if you still just hate
trump
okay so it's uh you know i still hate
trump as much as i ever did but i hate
how expensive gas is so i'm going to
become a republican and vote against any
of the pro-trump people
you're not a republican right they're
not right they don't know so look we're
politicos right we're we're deeply
entrenched in all this stuff the regular
person is probably sitting in their
living room and they're just like they
get or they come home from work and they
see their wife it's like how was work
and it's like honey man i don't know how
we're going to budget for this i mean i
just had to put 70 bucks in the gas tank
to get to work
we're not making enough money that's
just
this this this this biden this these
democrats it's like well i'm voting
republican they don't know what the
primaries are what they mean for the
most part they just know they get the
thing in the mail saying go vote and
they're like i'm voting republican but
if this woman represents uh some sort of
like key demographic of these people can
we show the quote again what she said
yeah
she said
i feel strongly their democracy is at
risk
and that people who are holding up the
big lie as we call it are holding on to
the former president are dangerous to
democracy
that is not just somebody who's like i
don't know how to budget for the month
and i don't really follow politics right
but this is one person
right but i'm just saying if she is
representative of the mentality of a lot
of these people making this this choice
so here's what they're saying they're
saying an ap analysis of early voting
from data firm l2 found that more than
37 000 people who voted in georgia's
democrat primary two years ago cast
ballots in last week's republican
primary an unusually high number of
so-called crossover voters even taking
into account the limited sample of early
votes i just gotta say in the absence of
evidence the solution that makes the
least amount of assumptions tends to be
the correct one and what we have seen
i mean i remember back in it was like
2019 or 2020
we had this c-span video
where
people were just calling being like i
have voted democrat for 20 years and i
am sick to my stomach of this i'm voting
republican
with these huge stories i mean you're mr
walk away how many people have you met
who walked away we had nine million
people in 2016 switch from democrats to
republicans the simple solution is
most people are just voting republican
because they're sick of the democratic
party
well i can tell you that in the
testimonials that we had before facebook
banned our group in 2021
uh the videos and the the written
testimonials were all people saying
that they had an awakening that
that i'd say the key thing that most
people had in common was an awakening
awakening that they were being lied to
manipulated and exploited and that that
awakening
led them to see
that trump
what they understood why trump was a
salvation to a lot of people and they
even considered i mean they said i'm
gonna vote for trump so it wasn't like
i'm gonna go you know hold my nose and
vote for trump this time or i'm becoming
a republican but i i'm just not gonna
vote for the president i mean they were
enthusiastic about trump all these
people walking the majority of these
people watching it it wasn't this woman
right it's a good point though that why
are they voting in the primary yeah well
i think part of the reason they liked
him so much is because in a sense
they're getting out of an abusive
relationship with a really terrible ex
and he's talking smack to him all the
time and they're like you know what i
kind of like this guy yeah
i don't know what do you think ian do
you think these are these are democrats
sabotaging do you think it's genuine uh
yeah there's probably some people that
are gonna sign up for the other party to
try and sabotage it but i think a lot of
people are disenfranchised with the
democratic i mean biden's near demented
at this state it's really hard to watch
him yeah i'm very gracious about saying
coming out and being like dementia
alzheimer's like i'm not a doctor so but
it seems that way and i mean the hillary
clinton email thing was insane the way
bernie sanders got screwed over two two
elections in a row cycles let me let me
ask you this way ian
if
i
made you an offer
a wager as it were
for one dollar
you could bet that biden is either
suffering from severe dementia or he's
not
and if you are right you would win one
thousand dollars which one would you
like
wait wait i should probably put it the
other way around what i'm trying to say
my point i love the man man i want to
help him if you had to wage you're a
thousand bucks and you could win a
thousand bucks
you know which one are you going to buy
you give me a thousand to one odds
whatever you could bet me a dollar for a
dollar i'd still say if he has dementia
i don't know but that's my guess
he shuffles his feet and looks at the
ground when he walks no one is going to
risk any amount of money like
like except for our entire economy
i guess 80 million people listen to him
do a video 10 years ago and then put on
a video from 10 weeks ago and it's like
two different people it's it's hot
terrified he's in charge of the military
yeah but sheamus
a lot of people in 2020 we had we had
coveted lockdown it was bad for a lot of
people and they said we need change this
was trump's leadership
they they probably thought it's gonna be
like obama all over again those years oh
man they're remembering being in college
or you know back in the good old days
and i was like i remember we should go
to the bar and play wii sports you know
like i got to vote for joe biden bring
back the obama era and now we're
bringing back flip phones vote
remember that terrorist story i was
trying to talk to my mother about the
tara read story because she didn't
really know it she's getting had been
getting a lot of info from cnn and it's
like no well i mean this girl i don't
know credibly accused that's a funny
buzz word incredibly but i mean she was
like he pushed me up against the wall in
the middle of the building capitol
building wherever they were and he did
unspeakable things yes horrific yeah and
she worked for him she was like one of
his aides and like that just got pushed
under the road totally pushed under the
rug i'm
lifting the rug up so you can look at it
tara reid look at her name it's
r-e-a-d-e by the way joe biden sniffs
little girls like this is not even up
for the debate there's videos of him
doing it and they don't talk about it
isn't that so bizarre that that's just
not even disgusting man has dementia and
he sniffs children constantly it's not
like a one-off thing i think here's the
thing now i know you guys are going to
call me crazy and maybe you know i
thought conservatives were against
cancel culture i can't believe he's
about to say this i think if you sniff
one child in public once your career
should be up
joe biden has repeatedly sniffed
children
and it is constant the first time he did
it they should have walked him off stage
and says let's not do that again it's
like when uh regarding his leg hair
being touched by the kids in the pool
that he was telling us about i gotta
have legs i think maybe that it was like
the kids were like oh it's a sea monster
because the hair was real long and he
was like ah you know the grandkids are
so probably not insidious i love when
the media runs these stories where
they're like conservatives believe in
conspiracy theories about a cabal of
pedos and all that and i'm like listen
listen i think those conspiracy theories
are pretty nuts but it's not helping
your case that joe biden is sniffing
children right on stage in front of in
front of the press and you're angry at
bills that want to prevent sexual
education for kindergartners through
third grade you're like oh no this is
the hill we want to die on and not just
that bills that say you can't have
secret conversations with children about
sex that you tell them not to report to
their parents
it's not happening i'm the only adult
you need to trust well that's the other
thing right it's not just that these
things are happening it's that the media
is either pretending they're not
happening or when they do talk about it
they try to completely twist the story
and gaslight you into believing that
you're the crazy one for being against
these these unspeakable things
you know that song institutionalized by
suicidal tendencies
i'm not crazy institution yeah we need
to make a modern version of that a cover
what's about the media and it's like i
turn on the tv i turn on cnn you know
i'm trying to figure out what's going on
in the world they tell me you know joe
biden didn't collude with the ukrainian
president to protect his son's business
and i'm like yo but there's video of him
saying it and they're just like and then
my mom comes in you know that song here
so the song is great it's funny one
thing i used to do um
i was i was doing a cartoon a while ago
about the uh scandal with ole joe biden
withholding funds from ukraine so that
they would uh
do his bidding basically and back off
the investigation into the the company
his son was working for yeah burisma and
i i was like well you know what it's
always good to get the other perspective
i don't want to spread misinformation if
i'm wrong about this so i looked up to
see what like the fact checkers were
saying because usually what they'll do
is gather all of what the left perceives
to be as the strongest arguments against
a conservative statement or position
and
i'm not kidding you the fact check i
read said well
it was actually obama administration
policy so it's mostly false to say that
joe biden was doing this for his own
goals or his own motives it's like what
he's the vice president of the
administration
they said that it was
obama's administration's policy to go
blackmail the ukrainian government yeah
yes
yeah i don't know i'd like to you know
you know i was thinking that's
interesting imagine this is a while
imagine anybody willing to vote for
joebite at this point that means they're
like well the economy is in the gutter
gas prices have shattered records
consistently inflation is shattering
records consistently he sniffs children
and they want to take away our right to
keep and bear arms like he is the
epitome of a fascist
and who's just destroying everything and
they would prefer that for what reason
but you just like very matter-of-factly
listed all of those things and it's like
that is insane that is actually
what is happening like that is the
president of the united states right now
i got the feeling that people were so
angry i don't know if anger is the right
word but so disillusioned or didn't like
trump so much they're like i will vote
for poop over that guy you give me a
steaming pile of poop and i will vote
for it but i don't know if that's
because they're like diluted on drug
like psychoactive pharmaceuticals and
they don't feel like they don't
understand maybe they're just low iq
maybe people just aren't as smart as i'm
giving them credit for and they're
voting with their gut
instead of their
logic the average person you mean like
when you're talking about the people who
voted yeah it's a good question i mean
so
like time magazine came out and
published a part an article where they
basically admitted that in every single
way they possibly could legally they
orchestrated the election to ensure that
they would get a specific outcome and we
live in a culture where people have been
consistently trained
to always take the path of least
resistance and do whatever brings them
pleasure as opposed to what makes sense
and what that results in is people who
are just followers and will basically do
whatever the media tells them get upset
about the issues the media tells them to
be upset about and vote for the people
the media tells them to vote for i want
to pull this tweet from michael malus he
said no one wants to take away your guns
no one wants to shut down your business
no one wants lockdowns to continue more
than necessary no one is going to force
you to have a vaccine passport no one is
teaching your kids critical race theory
these are all just conspiracy theories
that's right don't be concerned nobody
wants to indoctrinate indoctrinate your
children that's right
yeah that's never happened before that's
crazy yeah
they don't have kids they have yours i
like that he that he said uh they don't
it's not what does he say no one is
going to before all those statements
well said no one wants to yeah no one
wants to fill this in they didn't want
to you made them do it i used to joke
with my buddy matt and we'd be like it's
not that i hate you it's it's not that
you're an idiot that's not what i'm
saying you get it like you started off
with it's not that i mean you just say
what you feel
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you